there is a trade shortage expected in
the next few years so a local trade
school in Henderson is offering some
fast-paced training to try and fill that
need Mary Jane beliesza takes us to
Henderson with how the next generation's
Workforce is preparing
you could get wet you can get cut all
that good stuff in here Hugo clavijo is
a plumbing student at the National
Technical Institute in Henderson it's a
four-month trade school specializing in
electric HVAC and plumbing during the
pandemic he saw the need for skilled
trades I worked with my father-in-law
which he has handyman license so he
brought me a board hopefully once we're
out of here work for a business and then
the goal is to become My Own Boss Labs
like these ensure students are ready for
real life scenarios like labeling and
wiring to make sure your home runs
safely and smoothly I was a plumber
first became an instructor became the
director so when I talked with the
students I know what they're looking for
campus director Cody Wilson is positive
his students will land a job after
graduation three calls from companies
all the time asking how many people can
you send us how many people graduated in
the last couple weeks we're essentially
handing out jobs Wilson says in a few
years there will be many baby boomers
retiring from the workforce and with a
trade shortage already in place there
will be a high demand for these types of
jobs the trades are where we need to be
at otherwise we're going to see some of
our essential things
Skyrocket in price your plumbing bills
are going to be six seven thousand
dollars your HVAC bills are going to be
up to twenty thousand dollars because
there's nobody to do the work despite
short-term training you can still expect
a long-term impact for your future I've
got a lot of graduates that are out
there and they're successful already